welcome back to Facebook yesterday
Enrique Terrier the former head of the
so-called proud boys was jailed for 22
years for orchestrating the attack on
the US capital on the 6th of January
2021. it's the longest sentence handed
down so far over the attack his
supporters are now calling for Donald
Trump to say he'd pardon them and others
convicted over January 6th Trump has
plenty of legal problems of course of
his own the Fulton County Court to
dayhood arguments on his racketeering
case before my president pleaded not
guilty waiving his right to attend in
person would Jeremy discuss all this is
one of Donald Trump's most fervent
supporters at a regular on Piers Morgan
uncensored good to see you again Carrie
Lake how are you
I'm doing great thanks for having me so
look a couple of things uh off the top
here one the proud boys the leader
getting 22 years I've seen the reaction
to this a lot of people think good
justify the neo-fascists he was the
ringleader this is what he should have
got for what people are calling sedition
on that day and Insurrection and so on
others are taking a position that
there's an inconsistency here in the way
that they've been treated and along with
other January 6th riots compared to
other people who've taken part in other
riots what's your view
well I think Americans are coming around
to the fact that it wasn't an
Insurrection it was a staged Riot it was
a staged ride to cover up the fact that
they were going to certify a fraudulent
election and and here we're taking all
of these people many of them did nothing
wrong sentencing them to long sentences
in the DC Gulag while we remember the
summer of love as they called it in 2020
when we had BLM rioters and antifa
Riders literally burning down churches
torching cop cars beating people up on
the streets destroying businesses and
neighborhoods and they haven't been
punished at all and so everyone in
America is looking at this and saying
whoa we don't have Justice anymore in
America our our legal system is in in
Iraq and we can't even count on Fair
sentences for what happened there and we
know as we've seen tens of thousands of
hours of video some of it is starting to
come out we're seeing what really
happened happened on January 6 it wasn't
as the media described it it was not an
Insurrection and many of the people were
encouraged to go in by FBI informants
don't get too far ahead of ourselves
here the truth is that thousands of
people descended on the capital as a
howling aggressive and it turned out
very violent in some cases mob people
were killed that day and they broke into
the U.S capital the absolute epicent of
American democracy and they did it to
thwart democracy you might believe the
election was stolen Donald Trump might
believe the election was stolen but
actually most senior Republicans don't
think it was stolen most Americans
according to the polls do not believe
that election was stolen and actually
the enemy of democracy is not as you're
trying to paint it the FBI or those who
don't buy into the stolen election
narrative the enemy of people who
genuinely propagate the myth of a storm
election like you
well well let me just say one thing
about the people who were at the Capitol
that day there were hundreds of
thousands of people there peacefully
protesting saying we need relief because
that election was not fair it was not on
the up and up and there were some people
who went into the Capitol and there were
some instigators in that crowd and we're
seeing more and more of the video
showing what happened that day and
you're right there was somebody killed
that day Ashley Babbitt she was shot she
was shot by a capitol police officer and
he's never been brought to Justice on
that he's never been brought to Justice
a lot of the people that ended up inside
the capitol uh ended up there going
inside and the doors were opened by
Capitol Police there's a lot of
questions that remain and Americans
don't see that here's the question that
I would put to you Carrie if it had been
the other way around if Donald Trump won
that election be beaten Joe Biden and
these were Democrats hundreds of
thousands of Democrats storming the U.S
capital to try and stop that election
being ratified with zero actual evidence
of any election being stolen zero
evidence Trump's produced no actual
evidence which has been ratified by
anybody that this election was stolen if
it had been Democrats doing this I can
absolutely bet my house that you would
have come on this show and I'll give the
complete opposite
I know if if the November third election
would have been rigged and stolen the
way it was against the Democrats I would
be appalled as an American this isn't
about Democrat Republican it's about the
way that election was run and you're
saying there's no evidence Pierce but
there really is a mountain of evidence
and more and more of it's coming out
we're looking at what happened in
Michigan as more information comes out
about completely phony voter
registration we watched as they pulled
ballots from underneath tables after
they kicked the pole
stories swirling around but every single
time it's gone before people who
actually whose job it is to say whether
this has actually happened there's no
evidence I keep saying this Donald Trump
I don't know why he keeps vlogging the
dead horse of a stone election well
actually what he wants to be doing he's
trying to persuade people that he should
be elected again give us something for
the country to feel positive about he is
doing that
and he is doing that but the evidence is
coming out and I know it's probably not
being played in the UK but it is coming
out every day more and more evidence is
coming out about how bad 2020 was the
polls are showing that the majority of
Americans now believe that the 2020
election was wrought with fraud
that's true
so as we would say across the pond that
is an absolute no no 81 of Republicans
they're Republicans
you didn't say Republicans 81 81 percent
of Republicans 60 of Independents
actually the majority of Americans
the majority of Americans in every poll
I've seen do not believe that the
election was stolen you know why because
he wasn't stolen I'm I'm looking at
polls
I'm looking at polls and I follow
election Integrity because it is near
and dear to my heart
Gary I think what you want to do like
Donald Trump you want a fuel the sense
that every time you guys lose a fair
election it's unfair and rigged and
stolen and every time you win it's the
purest example of efficient working
democracy imaginable that's really what
it boils down to when Trump won in 2016
it was of course a fair election
suddenly when he lost well because you
just asked you said president Trump
needs to convince people why he should
win again why he uh why they should vote
for him and he's doing a great job of
doing that he's putting his agenda out
it's called agenda 47 laying out how he
is going to move America forward pull us
out of the ditch that Joe Biden and his
corrupt Administration has driven
America into how he's going to
strengthen us on a world stage we know
that we've lost our footing America used
to be a superpower and now we don't have
the respect around the world and I'll
tell you what Pierce if America Falls
the whole world goes and president well
I don't disagree with you and by the way
by the way Carrie I've just written a
big column for the New York Post which
has gone up tonight in which I'm heavily
critical again of Joe Biden I think it's
ridiculous that given his clear mental
failings is physical failings clearly
the age is now a massive issue uh I
don't think it's right that he should be
contested selection but nor do I think
is right that Donald Trump is facing
nearly a hundred criminal charges which
at the very least will swallow up almost
all his time in the next two years
you'll have no time to run the country
that's what they've intended
but my problem with that is a lot of
Republicans who when Hillary Clinton was
facing a similar scenario of criminal
charges all said that that would mean
she couldn't possibly run again then
I'll say in the complete opposite
thank you
I don't think she was ever charged with
anything no she wasn't but when she was
facing the possibility a lot of
Republicans said actually if she's
charged she can't possibly run again
the difference in America is that the
Democrats never get charged you know she
can uh you know bleach bit her computer
and and Destroy 30 000 emails and and
take money uh from all over foreign
interest into her Clinton foundation and
you know her friends can mysteriously
just commit suicide and die and and
nobody ever digs into anything the
clintons do well they did dig into it
all that was obviously dug into at Great
length by the media but I do think I do
think there is a bias skewed to
protecting the bidens in a way that it
would never happen if it was a trump all
this stuff with Hunter Biden which is
leading closer and closer now to the
White House and his father I think it
stinks to high hell and if they were the
trumps that were exposed to doing all
this it would be a ferocious Firestorm
all over the front pages every day so I
do think there is a double standard in
American mainstream media which skews
positive to the Democrats and protective
and goes against the Republic and on
that point we're going to end the
interview because we're going to reach a
rare point of agreement Gary but it's
great to see you
likewise thank you pierce come back soon